[Musique]
bonjour à tous content de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro dont on n'est pas
sorti de l'auberge alors c'est vrai qu'à
la Réunion on a la chance d'avoir un
terroir très riche et climat
suffisamment varié pour produire une
large gamme de végétaux la plus petite
des fleurs au plus grand des palmiers
aujourd'hui c'est café dont on va parler
mais pas de n'importe quel café vous
allez vite comprendre je vais rejoindre
Patrick Benard qui a ouvert ici sur la
commune du Tampon le domaine bien nommé
fleur de café je pense qu'il est en
train de travailler dans son champ donc
si comme moi vous êtes des amateurs de
ce breuvage je vous invite à me
suivre
[Musique]
comment vas-tu bonjour La for ils sont
beau hein tues café ah ils ont 8 ans ils
ont 8 ans ouais alors c'est du café mais
c'est pas n'importe quel café on est
d'accord alors c'est du Bourbon Pointu
donc un café originaire de la Réunion
ouais variété Lorina donc voilà je
cultive ce café depuis donc 2008 et bah
l'idée c'est de de d'agrandir les
surfaces et pour pouvoir répondre à la
demande actuelle
le café c'est c'est une culture qui est
vraiment riche pas seulement dans la
culture elle-même mais dans l'histoire
il faut savoir que le café c'est bah
c'est la première culture de l'île avant
le café ben il y a très peu d'habitants
sur l'île et dès l'arrivée du café bah
la réunion commence à se
peupler énormément justement pour besoin
de main d'œuvre pour ce pour ce cette
culture tout simplement il me semble que
c'est dû à ce besoin de main d'œuvre
qu'à la Réunion qu'on a édité le premier
code esclavagiste de la Réunion c'était
dû à à à la main d'œuvre nécessaire pour
pouvoir produire le café tout à fait
tout à fait donc Histor vraiment très
[Musique]
étroit la technique pour récolter le
café c'est alors la technique elle est
simple avec les
mains une sélection particulière o tu
sélection de couleur la première la
première la première gage de qualité
d'une cerise c'est vraiment la couleur
rouge bordeau il faut qu'elle soit pas
vraiment rouge donc ça on appelle ça une
cerise alors cerise de café exactement
du coup la récolte elle se passe sur
combien de temps alors la récolte il
faut compter entre 3 et 4 mois ça dépend
des années s'il y a beaucoup de soleil
en fin fin de saison ça va un peu plus
vite mais sil y a mauvais temps le temps
est couvert ça traîne un petit peu ça
peut aller jusqu'à 4 mois de récolte
effectivement et au niveau du du rapport
c'està dire que avec je sais pas moi 1
kg par exemple de de ceris rouge comme
ça on va avoir combien de café produit
fini alors on va faire dans le l'utre
sens on va dire pour il faut 8 kg de
café rouge pour faire un kil de café
fini donc si je va repartir avec mon
kilo de café fini on n pas fini la
matinée nous voilà il faudrait arrêter
de parler et ramasser plus rapidement
c'est toi la
pipelette petite technique pour le
ramassage vous
[Musique]
tournez en fait le bonbon pointu il est
si connu que ça pour quoi parce qu'il a
une notoriété mondiale en fait benah
déjà pas asses caractéristiques au
niveau saveur euh c'est un café qui est
bien particulier qui est différent des
autres qui qui est très léger en bouche
mais en même temps qui a énormément de
saveurs et et qui dégage des des des
saveurs et des arômes exceptionnelles
tout simplement au niveau du terroir
justement oui est-ce que c'est
simplement l'altitude qui va faire la
qualité ou c'est aussi la qualité du sol
et ce qu'on va avoir à l'intérieur du
sol la qualité du sol va jouer aussi
énormément faut savoir que le Bouron
pointu il est il préfère plus des sols
anciens donc coul de pyon des neiges
donc la zone favorable de la culture du
bon pointu on va dire donc de possession
rivière des galaes jusqu'à Saint-Joseph
rivière des rempards de 700 jusqu'à 1000
m d'altitude et vous êtes combien de
cultivateur en tout à la Réunion alors
en producteur on doit être environ une
une soixantaine et ça représente à peu
près une trentaine d'hectare et en ce
qui te concerne toi combien de alors moi
à terme on va dire j'aurais à peu près
un hectare en café hein voilà d'accord
c'est suffisant normalement sur 3
hectares on peut faire vivre une famille
avec uniquement du bois
[Musique]
pointu B on a donc fini la partie
récolte et puis on va pouvoir
s'intéresser à la transformation à
proprement
parler bonjour
bon alors une fois qu'on est du retour
du champ avec notre récolte c'est quoi
la suite du programme alors la suite du
programme c'est Jean-Pierre donc notre
qualité notre technicien qualité qui bah
qui prend en charge le produital bon ben
notre expert alors est-ce que tu peux
m'expliquer tout ça bah alors nous
premièrement on va peser le café ouais
d'accord l'identifier c'estàd le le
numéro de producteur le producteur le
numéro de parcelle d'accord vous
mélangez jamais les différentes
productions en fait tout est séparé j
jamais même si un producteur il a deux
lots différents de deux années
différentes il va séparer ces lot à la
récolte et ça c'est ça a quel intérêt
bah en fait c'est de voir l'effet parcel
en fait voilà du
coup on est dans des cafés de spécialité
donc il y a un effet parcelle sur le
café donc on essaie de d'aller jusqu'au
bout de on va dépulper le lot c'estàdire
dépulper c'est enlever la peau qu'il a
autour des graines donc la peau va être
éjectée on va garder nous les grains et
c'est sur les grains en quelque sorte
qu'on va travaillercord donc il va y
avoir une première étape de fermentation
une seconde étape de macération tout ça
sans additif ça se fait naturellement
cette méthode qu'on utilise là pour le
bon pointu c'est ce qu'on appelle la
méthode humide justement parce qu'on on
utilise énormément de l'eau comparé à la
méthode sèche qu'utiliser nos nos
ancêtres surtout à la Réunion et qui est
d'ailleurs encore utilisé dans le monde
où on met les les fruits tels qu'il sont
là à sécher au soleil en terme de
qualité c'est différent diff ça dépend
de ce qu'on recherche en fait
[Musique]
allez séchage en plein soleil hein
exactement c'est une une caractéristique
des cafés on va dire de de terroir café
Grand Cru donc c'est chage au soleil il
a raison pour que ce soit en escalier
comme ça ou aucune en fait alors nous ça
nous permet en quand il y a mauvais
temps attention ah pardon
de ranger les tiroirs et d'éviter qu'il
soit d'accordouill c'est un peu plus
ingénieux que de courir avec des baches
on est d'accord exactement donc là on a
les grains qui sont en train de sécher
donc entre le moment où on les met et le
moment où on les on les retire donc il
faut compter environ 12 15 jours donc on
va vérifier le taux de d'yrométrie on
appelle ça la teneur en eau donc qui est
de de 12 12 degr à peu près et là pour
le moment parce que vous vous pouvez pas
voir mais pour le moment il a vraiment
aucune odeur on est vraiment sur un
produit très très neutre là pour le
moment vous pouvez pas vous pouvez pas
sentir et là du coup on a encore la
petite coque exactement donc il y a une
autre étape qu'on va appeler le
déparchage parce que cette coque on
l'appelle la parche d'accord un peu
comme parchemin donc voilà l'autre étape
ça va consister à enlever la petite
parche la petite coque comme on dit et
là on a on a vraiment le grain de café
vert et tuue combien de d'agriculteurs
différents ici bah là on peut avoir là
on est à 60 une 60 de producteurs à la
coopérative
[Musique]
voilà là on arrive à l'étape de de la
touréfaction ouais et donc on va on va
mettre le café donc dans le touréfacteur
et on va le chauffer à 25
[Musique]
deg fait c'est une créfaction
traditionnelle une céfaction lente qui
permet de développer les arômes au
maximum voilà et donc après il va y
avoir brassage du café pour éviter que
le café continue à cuire parce que il va
tomber à 200° donc pour éviter qu'il
continue à cuire dans la masse ben déjà
on le brasse et en même temps il est
refroidi par un air
froid alors après la récolte ce matin
puis la transformation il est temps
maintenant de passer à la préparation
qui est un véritable si on veit un bon
Bourbon
Pointu impaion de goûter au fameux
Bourbons pointu mais avant ça il va
falloir passer à la préparation
exactement donc oui et avant de passer à
la préparation est-ce que tu peux nous
en dire juste un petit peu plus sur
L'endroit où on se trouve alors là vous
vous trouvez donc à fleur de café donc
c'est une petite structure donc
agrotourisme qui propose des visites
découvertes de bah du café Bourbon
Pointu alors visite découverte tu y a
quoi comme thème qui sont abordés alors
ben de A à Z on va dire depuis la
récolte jusqu'à l'arrivée à la tasse et
un petit peu d'histoire aussi et c'est
quoi c'est une clientèle qui est
principalement locale ou on a aussi des
gens de tout on a du du du des touristes
de passage et beaucoup aussi de clients
de passage c'est-à-dire que ça peut être
des étrangers euh des Chinois aussi des
Japonais évidemment et euh bah ils ont
entendu parler du produit mais ils
veulent le découvrir et ils veulent voir
d'où ça vient ben moi j'ai eu de la
chance j'ai pu découvrir tout ça ce
matin voilà et il me manque encore une
étape c'estàd goûter mais avant ça alors
la préparation donc est très importante
alors une chose alors la qualité de
l'eau ça représente quand même plus de
80 % 90 % du mélange donc il faut
utiliser une eau de source à pH neutre
et faible en minéraux ensuite donc cette
eau vous allez la chauffer à 94° faut
pas qu'elle boue en fait faut jamais
mettre une eau qui boue sur sur le
mélange de café
alors évidemment avant il faut mettre du
café dans la cafetière al c'est une ca
rés voilà c'est une cafetière donc à
piston alors le dosage il faut compter
70 g pour un L d'eau si je mettais
autant de temps à préparer mon
café j'arri au
bureau et donc là on est parti sur 5
minutes d'infusion on va laisser infuser
minutes et donc le fameux
café c'est un café qui est très léger en
bouche un peu acidulé qui a une amertume
très faible même des fois inexistante et
très léger vraiment café de dégustation
c'est pas le café qui va vous réveiller
le matin donc peu de caféine voilà du
fait que justement il est faible en
caféine
voilà
moi c'est quoi cet endroit où tu as
décidé de m'emmener là elle est
magnifique alors là ben en fait tu es
donc à l'horloge ferie c'est un point de
vue en fait bah sur le Bras de la Plaine
et bah on peut voir
encore la nature encore intacte et si tu
continues donc le Bras de la Plaine donc
tu remontes tu peux arriver jusqu'à donc
grand bassin et il y a un sentier aussi
qui ramène sur l'entre deux donc il y a
pas mal de marches à faire et bah le St
en face tout simplement j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de la faire une fois cette
Randon elle est magnifique mais elle est
extrêmement longue long pour les
sportifs pour les grands sportifs oui
dis je voulais en savoir un petit peu
plus sur la manière dont la filière
d'aujourd'hui la filière du Bourbon
Pointu d'aujourd'hui c'était c'était
initié on va dire que si une filière
pour moi personnellement qui a vraiment
une un avenir parce qu'aujourd'hui on a
quand même une demande de plus en plus B
plus en plus forte il faut vraiment
qu'on passe à une étape supérieure en
fait hein aujourd'hui et l'aspect public
c'està-dire le fait de vouloir faire
découvrir ça au touristes le fait de de
de de passer du temps parce que
j'imagine que ça doit prendre du temps
aussi sur sur tes récoltes tout à fait
c'est ça t venu comment alors au niveau
des visites ça c'est venu en fait les
visites sont se sont imposé
d'elles-mêmes on va dire c'est-à-dire
qu'au départ on était sollicité
justement bah pour faire des visites
mais c'est exceptionnel c'est-à-dire que
les gens voulaient connaître le produit
souvent c'était les clients même he
c'est des clients qui voulaient
découvrir le produit sur place et bah de
fil en aiguille l'idée est venu de là
quoi après on est parti sur une visite
structurée on va dire c'est pour ça
qu'au niveau des producteurs de B peintu
on a créé donc la route des cafillers
euh donc cette association avait
justement pour objectif a pour objectif
plutôt euh de faire découvrir justement
bah cette filière finalement et plus
personnellement toi et fleur de café des
projets euh bah à grandir ça grandir au
niveau des des des des parcelles mais
bon ça reste compliqué actuellement
l'urbanisation se fait de plus en plus
présente et donc bah l'idée c'est de se
développer agrandir les surfaces voilà
écoute je te remercie je te remercie
d'avoir répondu à mes questions je te
remercie pour cette journée je te
remercie pour pour ta passion et je te
dis à très très bientôt merci au revoir
patri et je te laisse avec cette
magnifique vue
d'ailleurs c'est donc sur ce sentier
d'ASS qui va me conduire au bras de la
Pline que va se terminer cette émission
j'espère qu'on vous aura donné envie de
découvrir ou de redécouvrir le fameux
café Bourbon pointu en tout cas si vous
cherchez un interlocuteur ça se passe à
fleur de café sur la commune du Tampon
et c'est Patrick Benard en ce qui nous
concerne on se retrouve très très vite
sur les routes de la réunion à
[Musique]
plus